en el vídeo pasado definimos lo que era
una transformación que era simplemente
una función que operaba en vectores
ahora vamos a hablar de un caso especial
de las transformaciones vamos a hablar
de las transformaciones lineales
transformaciones
lineales
después de todo esto es álgebra lineal y
ya hemos hablado acerca de combinaciones
lineales así que tiene sentido que
hablemos de algo como las
transformaciones lineales y que son pues
si tenemos una transformación t
que tiene dominio rm y que va a rm
entonces
qué es una transformación lineal que es
una transformación lineal
sí solo sí
si solos y qué pasa pues si tenemos dos
vectores y tenemos dos vectores en
nuestro dominio el vector a y el vector
b
rm que es nuestro dominio entonces vamos
a pedir que la transformación aplicada a
la suma de a y debe la transformación
del vector que resulta de hamás b sea lo
mismo que tomar la transformación y
aplicarse la a
y al resultado sumarle la transformación
aplicada al vector d
que estas dos cosas sean iguales
recuerden que estos dos son vectores en
rn y se pueden sumar y estos dos son
vectores en r m y se pueden sumar ok y
también voy a pedir también voy a pedir
que si yo multiplico al vector a por una
escalar c por un número real c entonces
esto o sea lo mismo que multiplicar hace
por el resultado de aplicarle la
transformación a a si estas dos
condiciones se cumplen para una
transformación te decimos que es una
transformación lineal bien ahora vamos a
ver si podemos utilizar estas
condiciones para determinar cuando una
transformación es lineal así que vamos a
suponer vamos a suponer que tengo una
transformación t que va de r 2
r2
y que está definida mediante la
transformación de x 1,2 es sencillamente
la pareja o el par ha ordenado x 1 + x
2,3 veces x 1
y por supuesto también podría escribir
esto en notación vectorial porque en
este caso estoy usando la anotación como
una pareja ordenada pero también podría
escribir esto como la transformación
aplicada al vector
x 1 x 2
es sencillamente el vector
el vector x1 más x 2
y segunda entrada 3 veces x 1 así que
esto es lo mismo que esto y de hecho
otro modo escribir lo que ya había usado
en el vídeo pasado y en algunos vídeos
anteriores de hecho es decir que t
te funciona mediante la regla de
correspondencia y al vector x1 x2
no envía lo transforma en nuevo note en
esta línea vertical de aquí
en el vector x1 más x2 y segunda entrada
3 veces x 1 muy bien pues vamos a checar
que esto vamos a checar si esto es una
transformación lineal
muy bien entonces queremos ver queremos
saber si t
es una transformación lineal
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es checar
que se cumplan estas dos condiciones o
que no se cumplan esas condiciones así
que necesito dos vectores en mi dominio
mi dominio es r 2 así que vamos a
considerar a a entre 2 como el vector
como el vector a1 a2
y vamos a considerar también un vector b
r2 que va a ser b1 b2
ok en este caso cuánto vale a más ve
quién es el vector además ve pues por
definición la suma de vectores es
sumarlos entra de entrada así que
primera entrada más primera entrada a 1
más b 1
sería a 1 v1 y hacer mi primera entrada
y mi segunda entrada es a 22
a dos dedos
ok
entonces cuánto vale la transformación
aplicada al vector
más de cuánto vale la transformación
aplicada la suma del vector con el
vector b pues esto es lo mismo
que tomar la transformación de el vector
lo que vamos a encontrar es aún no más
de uno
y a 2 b 2
más veloz
quiero encontrar la transformación de
ese vector
pues eso que me dice la regla de
correspondencia me dice
toma la primera entrada y sumarla con la
segunda así que sería uno más b 1 todo
eso es mi primera entrada más a 2 + b 2
a dos dedos que es mi segunda entrada y
luego tres veces la primera entrada así
que tres por uno más de uno
si quisiera podría distribuir al 3 pero
vamos a dejarlo así
ok muy bien este fue el resultado de
sumar los vectores y aplicarles la
transformación ahora voy a aplicarle la
transformación a cada vector y sumar el
resultado así que primero necesito
averiguar cuánto vale la transformación
aplicada al vector a cuánto vale td a
pues eso es lo mismo que la
transformación aplicada al vector a1 a2
y eso cuánto vale pues aquí sólo tengo
que sustituir x 1 por a1 y x2 por a 2 y
el resultado sería
a uno más a dos
y segunda entrada tres veces a uno
y que debe pues si le aplicó la
transformación ab
es algo enteramente análogo es el mismo
procedimiento y obtendría
b1 b2
tres veces ve uno
muy bien y ahora el momento la verdad
cuánto vale la transformación aplicada a
más la transformación aplicada a b
pues tengo que sumar este vector con
este vector la primera entrada es a uno
más a dos más
b1 y b2 y la segunda entrada sería tres
veces a uno más tres veces b 1
ahora esto es igual a esto pues resulta
que sí
si aquí como estos son números reales
los puedo conmutar los puede
intercambiar y escribir esta suma como a
uno más de uno más a dos más b2 y aquí
abajo
puedo factorizar el 33 por uno más de
uno
y esto es igual a esto así que la suma
la transformación aplicada a la suma es
lo mismo que la suma de las
transformaciones muy bien y que hay de
esta condición la condición que me dice
que aplicarle la transformación a una
escala por el vector
es lo mismo que multiplicar el escalar
después de aplicar la transformación
pues vamos a checar esa condición vamos
a checar esa condición así que nuestro
vector a de nuevo va a ser el vector a1
a2 y entonces cuánto vale sep ahora pues
se x a él simplemente c por el vector a1
a2 y por la definición del producto por
un escalar esto simplemente es ser por
a1 separados
muy bien entonces cuánto vale la
transformación aplicada al vector sep
ahora
pues eso es aplicarle la transformación
a este vector
y eso la regla de correspondencia me
dice suma las dos entradas así que será
uno más separados
y hasta tres veces la primera tres veces
por año
muy bien ok y ahora cuánto vale esto
pues puedo factorizar la c
sepor a uno más a dos y abajo
simplemente escribirlo como c por tres
veces aún no recuerden que ese es un
número real así que conmuta con el 3
bien y ahora esto es lo mismo que c x
a uno más a dos tres veces a uno
pero quién es esto pues este cacho de
aquí este vector es la transformación
aplicada así que esto es en realidad se
porte de a
esto ya lo hemos calculado acá arriba
acá lo tenemos donde está aquí está muy
bien así que la segunda condición la
segunda condición también se cumple de
modo que esto es una transformación
lineal
es
transformación lineal muy bien y quizás
estén pensando que entonces todas las
transformaciones son lineales pues vamos
a ver un ejemplo de una transformación
que no es lineal bien entonces para
entrar encontrar una transformación
una transformación que no sea lineal
vamos a considerar t
de r2 en r2
definida como
del vector x 1 x 2 sencillamente va a
ser
tomar la primera entrada y elevarlo al
cuadrado y la segunda entrada siempre va
a ser cero vamos a considerar esta
transformación y vamos a ver que no es
lineal si nos tomamos un vector genérico
en r2
que como sería pues de nuevo sería la
forma a 1 a 2 cualquier vector se puede
expresar en esta forma así que es un
vector genérico representante de la
forma más general posible ok entonces en
este caso para esta transformación de
cuánto vale de d
de la transformación del vector a puede
simplemente tomamos la primera entrada y
le elevamos al cuadrado así que a 1 al
cuadrado y la segunda entrada es 0
ok eso estuvo fácil ahora bien cuánto
vale una escalarse por nuestro vector
pues ya vimos esto arriba esto es separa
1 x 2
y entonces cuánto vale cuánto vale la
transformación de por el vector
toma mi primera entrada y la elevó al
cuadrado por 1 al cuadrado
sepor a 1 al cuadrado es que al cuadrado
por a 1 al cuadrado al cuadrado por a 1
al cuadrado como esto es un escalar
acuérdense es un número real y aún no
también la segunda entrada simplemente
es cero
y esto cuanto después puedo factorizar
laxe cuadrada
y obtengo a 1 al cuadrado
recuerden que sea el cuadrado por cero
es cero así que no pasa nada pero este
caso aquí este cacho de aquí este vector
quién es pues acabamos de ver que es la
transformación aplicada al vector así
que esto es lo mismo
se al cuadrado porte de el vector
bien entonces tenemos un problema puesto
que la transformación aplicada hace por
el vector
es igual hace al cuadrado por la
transformación del vector a entonces
como tengo este cuadrado tengo este
cuadrado de aquí no puede ser una
transformación lineal pues si fuera una
transformación lineal debería ser sólo c
no sé al cuadrado así que la segunda
condición la segunda condición no se
cumple y entonces entonces puedo afirmar
puedo afirmar que esto de aquí no
transformación
lineal
y bueno esto es esto es algo interesante
porque entonces podemos darnos cuenta
que generalmente las transformaciones
lineales son aquellas cuyas entradas que
mandan a vectores cuyas entradas son
combinaciones lineales de las entradas
de el vector original y en general en
general cuando empiezan a aparecer cosas
como el producto de las entradas otros
exponentes de las entradas ya no se
trata de transformaciones lineales
esto no es una regla 100% certera pero
da una buena noción de cuando alves una
transformación lineal y de hecho esto va
a ser bastante útil en el próximo vídeo
nos vemos entonces